33 مقاله اخباريه يستند اليها هاري في
شهادته ضد مجموعه صحف مرر يقول ان فيها
معلومات من المستحيل ان يكون قد حصل عليها
الصحفيون من دون تجسس عليه وعلى المقربين
منه فهارفي مهمه ليس فقط لتغيير المشهد
الاعلامي وانما لمحاسبه المسؤولين عن
معاناته في علاقاته السابقه وفي معاناه
والدته
[موسيقى]
المحامي المرموق اندروغرين لم يرحم هذه في
جلسه استمرت اكثر من ثمان ساعات على مدار
يومين دخل في تفاصيل المقالات معلومه تلو
الاخرى اتعبت الامير الذي بدا عليه
الانزعاج احيانا رغم ربطت شاشه بشكل عام
بالنسبه لمحامي الدفاع ادعاءات هاري تستند
تكهنات وليس لمعلومات وادله كافيه
[موسيقى]
احب الرجل لكنني لست مهتما حقيقه بالموضوع
انا احاول مواصله حياتي اتمنى له كل
التوفيق لكن لاكون صادقا لا اتابع الموضوع
لانه اصبح لدينا الكثير من الاخبار حول
هاري
اعتقد انه يتم اعطاء الموضوع اهتماما اكبر
من حجمه اعي انه يريد خصوصيته لكنه بعد
ذلك عندما قرر ترك العائله الملكيه
والذهاب الى الخارج وبالتالي هو يحصل على
ما يعطى له
[موسيقى]
لكن المشار اليها والذي تردد اسمه مرارا
القضيه كان له تعليق ساخر
اتطلع الى قراءه حملته الخاصه في كتابه
القادم وليس من المتوقع ان يعلق قصر
باكيهم على القضيه التي تتعلق باحد افراد
العائله الملكيه علما ان شعارها المشهور
لا تتذمر ابدا ولا تشرح ابدا من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات